early last week or middle of last week i
came to you and i told you that donald
trump is now conducting a frantic and
frenetic search for criminal defense
attorneys why well
he and others increasingly believe that
an indictment criminally is at least a
real possibility real enough that he
truly needs to have criminal defense
attorneys ready to go it appears as
though that search is not going
particularly well and there's a few
reasons for that as the washington post
reports trump is rushing to hire
seasoned lawyers but he keeps hearing no
the for this is just an unbelievable
line
the former president's current legal
team
includes
a florida insurance lawyer
who's never had a federal case
a past general counsel for a parking
garage company
and a former host at far right one
america news
can you imagine that as the former
president of the united states
this is the struggle that you are
experiencing he is rushing to assemble a
team of respected lawyers but the answer
they keep hearing is no
the struggle to find expert legal advice
puts trump in a bind as he faces
potential criminal exposure from a
records dispute with the national
archives everyone is saying no said a
prominent republican lawyer who like
some others spoke on the condition of
anonymity to discuss confidential
conversations
long time confidence of and advisors of
trump have grown worried about trump's
current stable of lawyers noting most of
them have little to no experience in
cases of this type according to two
people familiar with the discussions
taylor budowick a trump spokesman
defended the quality of the former
president's legal team in a statement
tuesday
but it is not particularly good john
sale a prominent florida defense
attorney who worked on the watergate
prosecution team said he turned down
representing trump because he didn't
have enough time
you have to evaluate whether you want to
take it it's not like a dui it's
representing the former president of the
u.s and maybe the next one in what's one
of the highest visibility cases ever so
normally as the article says it's
prestigious and and creates a lot of
publicity when you represent a former
president
but
this is a very different situation and
we have to be able to kind of just say
we we know what's going on here right i
mean big picture look at what has
happened to the people that defend trump
you end up disbarred
you end up subpoenaed you end up
indicted you're left with an unpaid
legal bill at the end of the day you
become ridiculed i mean sidney powell i
am sure and sydney powell is probably
wackier than the people that they've
been trying to get to represent trump
sydney powell i'm sure believed
this is my ticket to legal fame this is
my ticket to legal riches i'm going to
get so many clients and it'll be so
prestigious and the pr will be great and
then she starts going around with rudy
giuliani and doing these completely
humiliating um appearances everywhere
and she ends up disbarred and i think it
was new york and dc i don't remember off
the top of my head it doesn't go
particularly well look at what happened
to michael cohen look at what happened
to giuliani sydney powell i mentioned
and others of
uh
eric i forget the guy's last name all
these different people who have
represented trump it doesn't go well
and he often doesn't pay now we learned
that the republican national committee
has been paying some of trump's legal
bills for a period of time and we talked
about why when we discuss that
but it is not a guarantee that you will
even be paid for your work
remember the story about one of the law
firms that trump had representing him
years ago
they would always send two people
whenever they had a meeting because
trump would often lie about what he said
to his own attorneys in previous
meetings so they wanted two people there
so that they could counter the
falsehoods and correct the lies these
were confidential meetings with his own
lawyers and trump would still lie
and of course as a more general thing in
representing trump one of the biggest
problems with him as a client is he
can't just shut up
he can't just say nothing and if you
think back to the russia probe the
mueller probe whatever you want to call
it
if trump had never said anything
and not attempted to obstruct or tamper
with witnesses or any of it trumpet just
said
i am busy being president
i will allow the investigation to run
its course
it would have been over much faster and
trump would have been under much less
legal jeopardy and so it's hilarious
typically representing a former
president would be a tremendously
prestigious and great thing to do and
lucrative
but it seems like representing trump is
none of those things and couldn't have
happened to a nicer guy